[Music]  what's this  you folks need to turn around pretty bad  accident up ahead anything we can do  your doctor or something or something  nice doll that's what you think de work  be evil is contained how could you not  tell me you're babysitting for the horns  tonight yeah we'll be back early  tomorrow morning laughing don't your  parents keep any creepy stuff around and  keep it all locked away in the room it's  not good for anyone to go in there my  dad says that everything in there is  either haunted cursed or he's done some  ritualistic practice what's that this  area now they put coins went over the  eyes and the dead so he could take their  souls  what about the doll that's in there and  about she's in a case for a reason  [Music]  Anabelle mr. beacon father spirits  mrs. Wu okay something is happening  inside your house and we're not really  sure what to do  can I speak to Annabel I'm sorry you  need to give her a soul dear  you